gaitin's on the burger show gayten's on
the burger show
kate is on the burger show okay it's on
the burger show
[Music]
stranger things star gayton matarazzo is
just one of those people who makes me
happy every time i see him on screen his
character dustin brings back so many
fond memories of my childhood so when i
had the opportunity to make a burger for
him i had to go all out and do something
special i designed a custom stranger
things burger and like the show it's
adventurous it's weird and it's out
there get ready as i mold gaton into the
ultimate burger pro and hopefully earn
his cosign along the way
welcome to the burger show
having me how are you welcome thank you
so much welcome to the last time you're
on first we feast oh yeah you got it you
had to face the wings of death yes two
of them
boom
boom
hitting some push-ups
what
get it today it's a cake walk cool but
you're not off that easy okay we're
gonna cook oh you know i don't know what
you would rate yourself as a cook
uh it's it's weird because most things
it's it's like a two a two yeah mostly i
don't cook a lot but like for some
things i'm great like i know how to make
like the best
kraft mac and cheese on planet earth
we're known for meat cheese bun in on
this show okay as it is the burger show
as it is the burger show but we're gonna
do something a little different okay
okay because everything in the upside
down is just upside down it's upside
down it's weird uh-huh explain that what
like what is the upside down okay it's
just a real weird weird
bad version of the world that we live in
now there's no people there and
everything's gross and slimy and cold
and there are things that want to kill
you and stuff so we're gonna go there
we're gonna go there we're gonna go
weird okay we're gonna make a burger
inspired by
things that i feel okay would be at
the upside down would be in the upside
down first element is check out this
button i was gonna say that's the bun
this is like that's a weird looking
vegetable i could not even i couldn't it
looks like a truffle yeah it looks like
a big okay so i just i figured the
upside down is very dark yeah you know
weird looking it is so why don't we get
the weirdest looking bun
and this is a burger bun made of
activated charcoal and poppy seed
when you said it was a bun i thought it
was like pumpernickel or something but
now that i'm opening up it's got like a
weird like gray all the way through it's
completely gray so let's toast that up
okay i don't know what it is about the
upside down it's like some venoms like
hawked a bunch of loogies all over the
place that's exactly what it is right
it's literally the land of loogies but
there's also like these weird vines or
tentacles yeah and they're a lot we can
start on this which is the tentacles or
there they are
red onions perfect okay lightly coat
this in flour
okay and then we're gonna throw it in
this oh i see a little pop straight are
we gonna be frying these onions right
now oh yeah
oh
man that sounds good that probably looks
good huh just toss it lightly huh get a
nice little coat on there look at it
look at me go
you're cooking i'm cooking i'm gonna use
this really cool
i love that strainer you not love that
sound no dude when i hear things frying
i automatically get hungry it's perfect
it's amazing i like just the reason i'm
saying these things is because i've
never been on a cooking show and anytime
i watch them they always like just like
comment on everything going on around
them so yeah it's going to pretend like
it smells good that looks like
tentacles tentacle vines it looks like
tentacles okay so mission one
accomplished
right here boom
boom
done all right we have these two
balls beef bowls so these are very cool
a blend of
chuck brisket short rib
american wagyu trim
rib eye it's like the good guy this is
the premium this is primo style you want
to put them towards the center of this
skillet okay yeah and then we have this
thing
and look it you just press it down like
this oh
what
can you try and get it nice and flat
look if it gets if it falls apart it's
pretty much doing that it's all good
okay you just want to like
use this
back of the spatula yeah go ahead good
yeah push it down go crazy salt just a
little little pinch there like look at
that so this is my preferred method do
you see that beautiful browning that's
happening i do almost like taco meat
that is where the magic is okay that is
where all the flavor is let's take the
gloves off we're good
this is like yeah it's stuck on there it
looks like something like this i create
the ice off yeah this is a brittle
scraper i like it and we're gonna hold
the the skillet like this okay and then
a little something there so i don't burn
myself and then we're gonna scrape it
off the bottom
[Music]
oh yeah because it is it's pretty stuck
on there and then you can flip it
i flipped it
how you doing
so not good it doesn't look the
prettiest it doesn't but you did the
trick you see that beautiful brownness i
do okay i have one too that's gonna be
our top one i like it see how we have we
both have one that kind of just crumbled
and kind of just grab a piece of cheese
okay i'll grab a piece of cheese what do
we got here this this is american okay
that's like
bam and then we'll take our pretty
yeah okay the pretty patty and then
we'll throw that on top and look at it
just like that
what ugly patty there was no other there
was no ugly patty there wasn't you're
talking about got it yeah
we'll get there
yeah yeah yep you got it store them
right here okay perfect
got a little boom you gotta get ready
for this okay i'm ready plot twist
oh gosh there's lighting
your character really loves d d love
candy i've actually grown quite fond of
it myself really yesterday so you're
gonna like this okay cool open that
little velvet bag up this little velvet
bag yeah okay
oh look at that so a little what is that
that's uh right here it's a dye it's a
diet
it's the eight-sided dime okay so if you
get one through three yeah we're gonna
put a cheese sauce
dusted in hot cheetos
[Music]
to mimic okay
eleven's nosebleed that's disgusting and
awesome i know cool i love it that's
awesome and so four to six yeah
i'm gonna do a mac and cheese patty
deep fried
four to six okay deep fried cheese and
then seven and eight
we're gonna we're gonna give it an
homage to the 80s mall culture
and we're gonna do a dr pepper teriyaki
i want all of these things so let's
let's give it a roll doctor give it a
good old toss what is it uh six six we
get the mac and cheese that's mac and
cheese patty whoa
dude
let's just give it one more roll just to
see what challenge okay let's just see
because the thing is if like we get this
again then we know that we know this is
what the universe wants yeah so one two
three you're hoping for yeah let's do it
one two three
what is it that's an eight so that's for
the teriyaki we'll do teriyaki okay i'm
down for that i'm definitely you know
what yeah it is what it is get away from
the cheese all right so let me grab my
mac and cheese station i see [ __ ]
you could yeah we're good
we're good it's mac and cheese today
because this is america and this is what
we do with our lives yeah we're we're
getting it coated and then we're gonna
like knock a lot of that okay perfect
and then i'm gonna hit it in the egg
wash okay
drop it in
boom boom boom boom time yeah perfect so
we got we're golden brown we're
delicious it looks like it okay so now
we're going to build black garlic mayo
is a red relish it's roasted bell
peppers okay a little bit of habanero
okay there we go okay red
demogorgon blood blood everywhere
love it and then we have our patty looks
like and then this is our 80s dr pepper
dr pepper teriyaki teriyaki sauce if i
heard correctly we're just going to
drizzle it off get a drizzle it on there
load it up dude i'm a teriyaki fanatic
and a dr pepper fanatic just to go a
little more nuts we'll throw in we'll
throw in that we'll throw in the patty
it's the mac
and we're gonna put the tentacles
and then we're gonna
lit it
that's
it's so heavy it is
so heavy oh oh my god what did we make
right now that's that [ __ ] looks gross
but
it looks great it has to taste good
because i've tasted everything
step by step oh damn look at all that
juice coming yeah i gotta do that i
wanna show should we show everybody and
then like squeeze look at it that's
[ __ ] sweet about it look at that that
is
commercial level stuff you guys this is
it okay word
yeah dude you did really well i think
you got almost everything in one bite
yeah you did mm-hmm you got a whole you
got the whole thing
it's great
how is that mac cheese but i know you
were worried about it being too big yeah
if not no no no my favorite thing about
it is what is it it's the onions it's
the onions
and you were saying you weren't a big
fan before i've said it before i wasn't
a big fan
[Music]
we've changed his mind you've brought
your girlfriend with your girlfriend
lizzy let's let's let's let's bring her
out and let's let's
give her
the chance to judge your cookie you
wanna try burger
yeah look at it oh my god
i think i i have a feeling because i
smelled it from over there the teriyaki
sauce is going to come in
as like a bow you know what i forgot
about the teriyaki i got to take another
bite and think about it now you're
saying okay well then okay go for it
there you go that's a good bite
yeah you don't need the top one there's
a bun there's a bottom bun
what do we think right there
it's wild
i mean look you guys all the doubters
hit me on the comments i know you're
doubting it one out of ten how did he do
i really think it's like a nine or an
eight it's a nine well you know what
that's i had nothing to do with it
nine out of ten and it's inspired by
probably the ugliest place on earth the
upside down or not our earth but it's
the ugliest dimension ever in my entire
life i'm glad you guys like it thank you
ma'am i'm tapping out bye-bye
thank you so much thanks epic episode
try this at home
burger show we're out burger show
[Music]
what's up y'all it's your boy alvin
kylon of the burger show make sure you
like
subscribe and hit that notification bell
if not for me
for the burgers